♪ ♪
>> Sean: YOU THINK IT CAN’T
GET ANY WORSE FOR QUID PRO QUO
JOE.
HE DECIDED TO COME OUT OF HIDING
THIS WEEK.
IT WAS AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
A SMALL SAMPLE.
>> EXCUSE ME.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO
COUGH AND YOUR ELBOW.
I DON’T KNOW, SIR.
I LEARNED THAT ACTUALLY COVERING
YOUR WHITE HOUSE.
>> ACTUALLY, THAT’S TRUE BUT
FORTUNATELY I’M ALONE IN MY
HOME.
BUT THAT’S OKAY.
WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
CURE.
THAT WILL MAKE THE PROBLEM WORSE
NO MATTER WHAT.
>> WHY DOESN’T HE JUST ACT LIKE
A PRESIDENT?
>> THAT’S A STUPID WAY TO SAY
IT.
>> DONALD TRUMP --
>> SORRY.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> NO, NO, PROBABLY BEST I DON’T
DON’T.
I JUST CAN’T FIGURE THE GUY.
IT’S LIKE, I DON’T KNOW, IT’S
LIKE WATCHING A YO-YO.
I SHOULDN’T HAVE SAID IT THAT
WAY.
>> IT FEELS THAT WAY.
I WANT TO ASK --
[LAUGHS]
>> OUR SECRETARY OF STATE
INSISTED, IN THIS BROKE MEETING
UP IN TERMS OF INFLUENCE, THAT
THIS BE CALLED THE WUHAN VIRUS.
>> Sean: OH, BOY.
GOOD NEWS FOR BIDEN, MAYBE NO
ONE PAID ATTENTION.
ATTENTION.
A VIEWERSHIP FOR HIS VIRTUAL
HAPPY HOUR THIS WEEK, 2,800
VIEWERS.
JUST BREAKING TONIGHT, BIDEN,
AND ANOTHER LIE BECAUSE IT TURNS
OUT BIDEN-OBAMA SOUGHT MILLIONS
AND TDC FUNDING CUTS, COMPLETELY
UNDERCUTTING BIDEN’S SMEARS
AND LIES AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHICH ARE
SAVING THOUSANDS OF LIVES, OF
COURSE.
NOW BIDEN WAS ASKED ABOUT THOSE
MOMENTS AGO.
HE DIDN’T HAVE A GOOD ANSWER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SHOULD THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DONE MORE TO
REPLENISH THE SUPPLIES AND
PREPARATION FOR FUTURE
OUTBREAKS?
>> WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME -- I
WAS NOT PART OF IT.
OUR ADMINISTRATION SPENT A LOT
OF TIME WORKING WITH THE
INCOMING TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND LAYING OUT EXACTLY WHAT
COULD HAPPEN WITH THE FUTURE
PANDEMIC.
>> Sean: OH, BOY.
REACTION, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR’S
TAMMY BRUCE AND JASON CHAFFETZ.
60.8 MILLIONS OF AMERICANS GOT
THE VIRUS, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
HOSPITALIZED.
BY THE TIME I BOUGHT
BY THE TIME OBAMA AND BIDEN
DECLARED A NATIONAL EMERGENCY,
LOST 13,000 AMERICANS IN THE
YEAR, TENS OF THOUSAND
CONSTRUCTED APPEARED IN THE
MEDIA, WE DIDN’T HAVE THE DEATH
COUNT, THE CONTRACTING
COUNT THEN.
WHY NOW QUESTION LIKE THAT A
PANDEMIC, THIS IS A DIFFERENCE?
>> OBVIOUSLY THERE IS BIAS.
EVEN IN THE FIRST DEBATE WHEN
KAMALA HARRIS WENT AFTER BIDEN,
THE FACT THE QUESTIONS NOW ARE
BEING ASKED.
MAINLY BECAUSE I’M IN THE MEDIA
HAVE A CANDIDATE THEY PREFER
OTHER THAN JOE BIDEN BUT WHAT IS
FASCINATING AS TO WHY HE’S WEEK
WAS SO BAD, HE WAS TRYING TO
HIDE THAT THERE REALLY IS NO
COMPETITION FOR DONALD TRUMP.
IN THE OTHER PROBLEMS THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE IS THEY HAVE
SPENT OVER THREE YEARS LENGTH
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT
THE CAPABILITIES OF
DONALD TRUMP, AND NOW THAT HE
HAS DAILY UNFETTERED, UNFILTERED
ABILITY SPEAKING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, DEALING WITH A MAJOR
CRISIS FOR ALL OF US, THEY ARE
FINDING OUT HOW MUCH THEY’VE
BEEN LIED TO.
THAT IS WHY HIS NUMBERS HAVE
GONE UP SO CONSIDERABLY.
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU’VE GOT
THE ISSUE WITH JOE BIDEN.
IS THAT THERE IS NEVER REALLY
BEEN ANY REAL LEADERSHIP.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY KNOWS IT.
AND THEN THEY COMPLAIN THAT
THEY’RE GETTING BLOWN OUT BY
DONALD TRUMP.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, I
REMAIN IN MANHATTAN.
WE ARE REACHING THE WORLD HERE
THROUGH MODERN NEW TECHNOLOGY.
ME FROM MY APARTMENT.
JOE BIDEN HAS EVERY CAPABILITY
OF REACHING PEOPLE IF THEY WERE
INTERESTED, AND THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT A LACK OF
ENTHUSIASM, WHICH IS WHAT WE’VE
SEEN, OBVIOUSLY, THE THE THE FOR
HE’S BEEN EXPERIENCING ONLINE.
>> Sean: HE GOT IT WRONG
AGAIN.
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA.
ENDOWED BY THEIR CREATOR, NO,
ENDOWED BY THE THING.
THE THING.
JASON, I DON’T CARE, BUT
WHATEVER TERM YOU WANT IT, THIS
GUY IS LOST IN SPACE AND IT’S A
LITTLE SCARY.
>> EVERY DAY THAT HE WAKES UP
AND THEY TURN ON THE CAMERAS IS
A BAD DAY FOR JOE BIDEN.
THIS PERSON WAS ELECTED TO THE
UNITED STATES SENATE IN 1972.
I WAS BARELY STARTING TO PLAY
SOCCER THEN.
HE IS ALL ABOUT YESTERDAY.
HE HAS NO VISION FOR THE FUTURE.
AND I’VE GOT A BEEF WITH YOU,
SEAN HANNITY, BECAUSE I HAD TO
WATCH PART OF THAT TOWN HALL TO
COME HERE AND TALK ABOUT IT.
LET ME TELL YOU, IT’S AN
EMBARRASSMENT BECAUSE HE LIKES
TO DO NUMBERS WHILE THERE’S TWO
THINGS HERE, AND THEN HE LOSES
COUNT.
AND THEN HE HAS TO GO BACK TO
NUMBER ONE, IN ONE QUESTION HE
WENT TO NUMBER 13 TIMES.
>> Sean: THIS IS MY FAVORITE
MOMENT.
HE’S DOING THE TOWN HALL THING
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN HE FORGETS
HE IS ON CAMERA AND THEN HE JUST
STARTS TALKING, WALKS ON
CAMERA -- I MEAN, THIS IS NOT.
TAMMY, THIS IS SERIOUS NOW.
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE NEEDS STRENGTH, STAMINA,
MENTAL ALERTNESS.
YOU NEED TO BE SHARP.
>> THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS, IT IS VERY HARD TO
BELIEVE -- AND LOOK, THE 2020 20
CAMPAIGN HAS ESSENTIALLY BEEN
PUT ON HOLD, RIGHT?
BUT IN THE TRADITIONAL WAY, THE
TRADITIONAL RALLIES FOR
DONALD TRUMP HAVE BEEN PUT ON
HOLD, BUT THE DEMOCRATS I THINK
STILL ARE LOOKING FOR A WAY TO
GET OUT OF THIS, AND IT DOESN’T
MEAN THEY EVEN HAVE THE BROKER
CONVENTION IN A CLASSIC SENSE.
SOMEONE COULD STEP UP CLOSE TO
WHENEVER THEY HAVE THEIR
CONVENTION COME IF THEY ARE
STILL ABLE TO DO IT, AND SAY
LOOK, WE AGREE HE’S GOT TO GO,
HIS FAMILY --
AND WATCH OUT FOR SOMEONE LIKE
CUOMO, WHO THINKS HE’S THE ONE
WHO CAN BEAT DONALD TRUMP HERE
TO WATCH OUT FOR THAT.